[Music]
the courtyard homeless Resource Center
making great strides in providing more
services as well as amenities for those
who are experiencing homelessness phase
two in the expansion process is now
complete Madison Kimbrough live in
studio tonight to tell us what that
entails Madison yeah Brian I got to
speak to those experiencing homelessness
firsthand about how they feel that the
resource center is expanding and what
they will now be offered
I come here to sleep at night they are
in the process of helping me get a
housing Harry Southworth has been
utilizing the courtyard homeless
Resource Centers services for years he
and others come to the shelter daily and
are very much aware of the need for
expansion our population is overgrown
and a lot of communities and
neighborhoods again concerned about us
you know overtaking their their space
the city recognizing this Jocelyn
Blewett Fisher the community resources
manager sharing with 8 news now the
progress that has been made in adding
additional Services phase two is now
complete and those services will be
ready to use by mid-april we will have a
laundry facilities washers and dryers
will have additional showers we have a
dog run in addition to our pet kennels
so our guests are actually able to take
their pets out of the kennel and play
with them and those with canine
companions feel lucky to have those
services available to them me and my
husband we have six dogs
so it's good because my calendar pets
where are your drugs now they're in the
kennel area
and the final piece to completing the
resource center will be phase three
where there will be the opening a
full-service Medical Clinic on the
corner of foremaster and Maine Brian